she always gives me that uncomfortable
feeling in the pit of my stomach
every single time it is good time thanks
Katrina I'm gonna talk today about
societal concerns and targeted
advertising and as katrina described it
may be a little bit uncomfortable just
to say that to put them up front i think
there are three major concerns that
targeted advertising system as they are
executed today create those are privacy
automation of hate and issues related to
discrimination and fairness and
throughout my talk I'm gonna use
Facebook as the motivating example and
use their systems as a way to explain
what is targeted advertising because
they were the pioneers in this space
have the most users and have the most
advanced features so what is targeted
advertising if I'm gonna talk about how
it creates societal concerns let me
first explain what it is and here it is
in the words of Sheryl Sandberg the
chief operating officer of Facebook from
just I guess a couple weeks ago it's
this idea that you can have advertising
that reaches the right person with the
right message at the right time which is
a useful thing for the advertiser and
for people to see ads that are truly
relevant to them which is supposedly a
useful thing for the individuals for
seeing apps so this is this is the goal
this is the the message that Facebook
has been aspiring to for the last decade
it's not more how do how is this
achieved well all of you know that when
you create an when an advertiser creates
an and what they put is they put text in
the image of what you'd like to see in
the nod and maybe a link to where the ad
goes when you click on it it could be a
webpage or
a Facebook page or in the vent signup
form etc what some of you may not know
is that now there is also this
additional thing that enables
advertisers to specify more precisely
who they want to target who are the
people that they want to see their ad
and then and this could be any number of
things it could be things like locations
it could be age and gender and languages
that the person speaks and then it's it
can be pretty much anything else that an
advertiser can think of from
demographics from interest from
behaviors there's a there is a hierarchy
of things that the advertiser can pick
from and then there's also a freeform
text where you can start as an
advertiser putting in things and see
what it looks like so for some examples
of what it could look like
you can pick people by behaviors you
couldn't say oh I want to target people
who are interested who are engaged
shoppers or who you know it's likely to
buy for Mother's Day so forth you can
pick people by education you can say oh
I want people who are getting their
doctorate degree at USC or who have
gotten their doctorate degree in the
past you can you can even choose people
by financial income and you can choose
pretty much by any other interest so for
example you can target people who are
interested in LGBT yeah so this was the
the the first venture into tore into how
targeted advertising looked like I
believe maybe a little wrong in the
dates but I believe this this concept
started around 2007-2008 for Facebook
and since then a lot of more advanced
features have been introduced in
particular one of the
one of the areas that Facebook has
innovated in is a so called
custom audiences feature where if you
have a list of people from say somewhere
else that you have reason to believe may
be interested in the product or whatever
it is you're advertising you can prepare
a file with this list of people upload
it to Facebook and for whoever is
matched on their side whoever is a
Facebook user you can say I want to show
my ad to these people and what can be in
this customer file is quite diverse it
can be anything from like email and
phone number
mobile advertiser ID but it can also be
first name last name address date of
birth so that's one very advanced
feature the other one and I really fit
Facebook's also pioneer here is called
look-alike audiences so you can create
this custom audience of people who have
perhaps previously interacted with your
product or your page and you can say
okay I want to find look-alike audiences
audiences that look like this this one
that I already have and show my ad to
those people and there's not much
information on how it's done it's a
black box algorithm on Facebook side but
they do is to find more people who look
like your current customers visitors or
page
so you specify using this so for example
if you're CBS you may have phone numbers
of people because they signed up for
loyalty cards right so you can just
upload the phone numbers here and that's
your past customers if you're just a
website you can have a Facebook pixel on
it and based on that you can you can
kind of the identified way but you can
have people who have previously no data
flows and so the idea here is that
argued advertising when executed in such
a way should be beneficial for everyone
so for example if I'm the marketing
director for stars or stars on ice and I
know I have a show coming up in Anaheim
then I don't want to just blast the ad -
everybody who lives around Anaheim maybe
I just don't have the money to to do
that I I want to show the ad to people
who are more likely to go to my event
and this may be people who you know who
are who live near Anaheim and are
interested in winter sports or it could
be parents of kids who may be interested
in this kind of event or it could be
somebody the type that they have another
access to that they subscribe to a
skating magazine and the idea is that if
stars are nice advertisers like this
using these kinds of criteria then it's
beneficial to them because it enables
them to spend their money efficiently
but it's also beneficial to users
because then the users don't just see
random ads of everybody in the world who
is advertising on Facebook but
theoretically they see ads that are more
relevant to them more of interest to
that that's that's the that's the
premise that's the promise of targeted
advertising and why
we slash the ecosystem slash Facebook
may want to do that
yes copy this targeting language is
accessible to everybody like if I wanted
to put in there do you know if they are
like larger advertisers yes so so there
first of all everybody can run an ad all
you need to do is you need to have I
think a Facebook account to run an ad
but maybe even that does not the
protocol and it's it's pretty easy to
get started and it's pretty cheap there
are features that are not accessible to
everybody for example there are advanced
features related to location targeting
so you could have a Facebook beacon in
your store and then maybe collect
information of who visited based on that
beacon and then maybe use that in a
custom audiences I'm not sure exactly
because you know in order to get to
those features you need to be an
advanced advertiser spending a lot of
money maybe have established a
relationship with Facebook so I do as a
researcher you are limited in to what
you can see but they were definitely I
sound advanced Jamie so so when an
advertiser selects these things
presumably Facebook will then promise to
like show their ads these people will
Facebook then like also give them
information about the advertisers right
great question thank you next back right
so the question is stemming from okay
now when these ads run what happens to
people who see these ads what happens to
their private
and from the very beginning of
establishing the system up until today
like if you look at the blog post at
their reference from two weeks ago it
mentions privacy again but from the very
beginning Facebook has said we have
designed Facebook to provide the
relevant and understand advertising in a
way that protects your privacy
completely we deliver the ad without
revealing any personal information to
the advertiser so this is a quote from
2007 but the Spirit has hesitate how
does facebook achieve that so when an
advertiser places an ad they don't get
to see who specifically saw them so if
you have a custom audience and includes
names of people when they run an ad they
don't get back oh these people saw the
ad and these people didn't see yeah we
don't get the user names they don't they
don't get any immediately identifying
information but they do get very
detailed information about campaign
performance so that includes the number
of impressions the ad has received the
number of clicks the number of unique
people who saw this ad there are other
engagement metrics but these are kind of
the main the main three and then they
also get a breakdown by age and gender
and location so you can see how many
people are in this age range who are
female in this location so so now yes
just a small thing so the Facebook
doesn't share this data with the
advertisers but app developers they're
built on Facebook do have access to a
lot of personal data and I think the
whole Cambridge analytical comes from
that side so it's related to political
targeting but not to this
and this has caused me a lot of
confusion before because Facebook has
been saying this for a long time and I
work with people who did the advertiser
confirm this but then when you look on
the other side of the api's it's
different so just a remark Thanks
so I think let me say that I'm talking
specifically about their concerns and
advertisers and targeted advertising and
what the advertisers say I cannot cover
today the situation with Facebook in
general and developers and it is can I
agree with you hundred percent against
my cat so now some of you are privacy
experts when you see something like this
and the promise of privacy I think
everybody like you know I saw Adam
smiling so like everybody's like yeah
okay well let me break this the the this
must be broken there's for one thing
there is no randomization right so most
likely this is broken in just a matter
of how to break it and that's how I
thought also 9 years ago and here is an
example of how to break the privacy of
this say you want to learn something
about me so you want to learn whether
I'm single and married ignore that you
can look at my finger figuring that out
this way so what do you do you quickly
Google me and you find out Oh Alexandra
oh she grew up in Latvia and then you
know Katrina introduced her - she's at
USC and then before that she studied at
Stanford and was you know the student at
Google and in general when she is not
carrying people she works out any
differential privacy so this is what you
know about me in like two seconds from
very public information so now this is
what you do you become an advertiser and
you run two different campaigns
there is one thing that's common about
these companions they want to target a
person who graduated from Stanford born
in Latvia what a Google now works at USC
is female
this is enough characteristics to say
that this is a unique person and now
these campaigns different to the there's
two compared one is targeting people who
are married
the other one is targeting people who
are single so you run these campaigns
you just place them run them and what is
gonna happen only one of these campaigns
will actually be shown because I'm
either single or married I'm not both at
the same time so only one of these
campaigns will be shown and you as an
advertiser get to see the number of
impressions that the campaign has had so
even if I don't click you are gonna know
which one is the answer for me just by
observing the number of impressions that
the campaign you don't need to know
where it's been shown you're
guaranteeing that you're learning about
me by specifying me pretty uniquely this
is a pretty unique right so you know
that the only person who really matches
the criteria of the campaign is is me
and then if if I'm if I were single then
I would match this campaign if I were
married then I would match this campaign
so when you run both campaigns doesn't
matter where as long as I'm a Facebook
user ah only one of these campaigns will
be shown to me take a demonstration
they're making here but like I'm curious
if they doesn't have information about
like your magical status at all like how
would you feel confident about this
result so if it's like zero and zero
good question so what you learn is not
necessarily true information about me
you learn what Facebook believes about
me and that's maybe incorrect but in
many cases it can be accurate because on
many people they do have a lot of the
data so yes great great question
so I disclosed s to Facebook when I
discovered it and they said oh great
this is this is a problem we're gonna
make sure that the audience that you're
targeting is at least twenty people and
we're not gonna allow running campaigns
otherwise and I hear Adam again
smiley cuz you know what what is twenty
people and why twenty people and of
course we can overcome this twenty
people by maybe creating fake accounts
etc etc and actually for the
differentially private minded folks here
you know the fact that it's a precise
threshold can itself be exploited to
leak information the same way but then
also right so this was before there was
the custom audiences so now there is the
custom audiences and now creating these
twenty people groups is very very easy
because you can just upload my
information and information now nineteen
other people so Facebook on their side
has some protections to see that maybe
those people are real and I believe that
the threshold on custom audiences is
larger at this point but it's still
vulnerable so for example there is
another feature that they didn't tell
you about which is called audience
insights so for custom
audience that you create or you get from
somewhere else you can own this custom
audience you can get insights about the
people who are in this audience and
there it's more rich than just gender
and age and location you can get their
interest and you can get what pages they
like and recent activity and household
income etc etc what kind of lifestyles
they leave and so forth and the idea
again here is to help advertisers
understand the audience is better so
that they can then better target their
ads and reach more relevant people right
but it turns out that this combination
of custom audiences and audience
insights now made the attack no even
even simpler you didn't even need to
Google about me and get some information
about me after web what you could do
until 2018 is you could run this
audience insights on a custom audience
of one you just create a custom audience
of one person then not even create the
ad campaign go to audience insights and
see what kind of information we reported
this to Facebook it also got the bug
bounty and they fixed it yes
how many false positive impressions do
your final Facebook algorithms for
example of someone start from Stanford
but lips nearby is there also some
chance that that person will be showing
impression I don't know but my guess is
that Facebook is working really hard to
prevent mistake accounts fake clicks etc
so they are doing the best that they can
to to give me accurate information to
the advertisers so I I'm not sure that
they're succeeding that I think there
was a high profile case related to video
views where they were reporting
incorrectly the number
views the video has received but I think
they're working hard to be precise to
catch so and finally how if you're not
scared enough a lot of custom audiences
etc here's the deal if you actually
click on an ad all bets are off because
what happens is advertisers can
instrument the ads themselves to pass
along parameters which campaign they
came from and that in itself leaks that
you're part of the group that was being
targeted so for example if the the
targeting was engaged shoppers you click
the campaign of engaged shoppers then
you're on the website and then whoever
the advertiser is knows that you were
engaged
so the second you click yep your privacy
is not in a good state so that that
brings me to kind of the first
large-scale concern I think that arises
in targeted advertising it's the
question of privacy and how can one
implement this promise of win-win for
everybody
without really leaking private
information the way it's leaking in
current implementations and also I think
the current thought of targeted
advertising is you know if if we want to
show ads to people who are most
interested to them then we need to know
as much as possible about those people
and so that's leading to companies who
are not platforms to try to sweep up as
much information as possible about
individuals in order to target
when we take the engaged you're saying
that the privacy problem is when you
click you click that there's two things
that are happening one is that the
advertiser now knows can connect connect
to that but Facebook already knew
because they'd already put you in that
category of engaged shopper so when you
click that ad is Facebook are you saying
that the privacy issue it's twofold one
is that Facebook is now getting an
acclamation
of their having placed you in the
engaged shopper category does it not
update that so I mean it seems to me
there's two fold problems what is the
advertiser and the other one is Facebook
getting some kind of verification that I
guess they might at that about you and
placing you and that category is not
right so I was talking mostly about the
advertiser learning something through
the Facebook platform about you but you
also correct that Facebook of course is
also analyzing who is clicking what who
is spending how much time on viewing
which ad and learning additional
information about individuals that way
as well yes so both privacy concerns are
there
so on to my next privacy concern sorry
could not privacy concern societal
concern um
I think these platforms enable
automation of hate and this is maybe not
so surprising but I'm gonna show how
specifically in the context of our
targeting this happens and remember
remember again the detailed targeting
and where you can say I want to pick
people who are interested in specific
interests and I want to exclude people
who are interested in specific things
and this can be quite free for so
there's a lot a lot of things that one
can put here and as it turns out the
ProPublica did just that and it turns
out that if you're trying to find
like-minded people who hate Jews you
could do that on the Facebook platform
so you can you can just select okay I
want with my ad I want to reach people
who in who do haters who are interested
in how to burn Jews who I guess be
interested in the Nazi Party you could
you could run this ad and moreover when
Pro Publica running this ad Facebook's
automated system site is your audience
selection is great in response to
república finding facebook remove said
that they removed 5,000 categories from
from this list of interests at one
target but again when it's a free-form
list and you're removing categories by
hand I think it's pretty clear that you
won't get them all there's always going
to be something that you forgot to
remove or unless you really limit the
list to a small number of things that
you can review by hand and in fact after
the massacre in Pittsburgh another
reporter some little
saw that you could run in the campaign
targeting people who are interested in
white Jennifer so that's one way that
automation of hey it happens so if
you're part if you're one of those
people who hate you can't find
like-minded you can collect support for
your hate very easily and very cheaply
through the system here's another way
that you can automate hate remember I
said that you can target by location
your campaigns so in particular you can
target by people who live in in the
location people recently in the location
people traveling in the location and it
turns out that you can forget pretty
precisely so now even though nominally
there is a minimum one-mile radius for
which you target when you create an ad
campaign it's a very expressive language
so you can say I want to include people
in this one-mile radius and exclude
people in these one-mile radius is so
you draw a circle like this and then you
draw for three circles here and then
what you end up with is essentially a
building and you could say oh I want to
target people who were recently in this
location and this specific building is a
Planned Parenthood so now as an
advertiser you can run a campaign and it
doesn't even have to be it doesn't even
have to say oh you know you're killing
your baby you you can run a campaign
that just shows cute baby clothes or you
know cute babies in this campaign and
target it at people who are making a
difficult decision at the moment and
instead of standing with the posters
outside you can be anywhere in the world
making this decision
people we reported this to Facebook
working hasn't ended after about we mind
so back and forth
and by the way if you think that you can
control the location and you can prevent
this by by exercising the location
controls that Facebook provides you no
you cannot
the location controls are there but they
offer an illusion of control not actual
control first you can read mine my blog
post on this aren't just to see an
example from personal experience but
also even if you control as much as you
can the location that Facebook gets
through Facebook's group of ads there
are other apps who you may be giving
your location who may be relaying this
back to base so here we are we have
privacy we have automation of hate I
mean you say something just about why do
you call this automation of hate rather
than because this could be right I mean
you can actually empower those who are
going to abortion clinics and actually
you know you can target them in order to
show them there is no right you can you
can actually help people organize
against totalitarian governments I mean
it's not the automation is not just hey
but also whatever right depending on the
absolutely I agree with you completely
these these can be used both for good
and for evil
I call this automation because if before
you in order to do this in order to
target a small group in a going to a
particular Planned Parenthood you had to
pretty much physically stand there now
you don't have to physically so it
automates the process you can just be
anywhere in the world doing that and
it's a dimension of hate because hate is
one of the ways that you can use
it's not the only one but I'm not here
to talk about the positive things that
these systems bring I think we have the
whole Facebook and Google and Twitter
and whoever PR machinery to talk about
the virtues of these systems and I don't
deny them they they they are there but
there needs to be somebody talking about
the flipside of these systems as well so
I'm not somebody by virtue of being an
academic I would guess that there would
be some people that would say this
micro-targeting of people in planned
parenthood was a very positive
ramification up personally making this
claim but I think there are many people
who would say that that's a positive use
of Facebook's micro-cut targeting
whereas using it to like foment uprising
against a certain government would be
considered a negative thing I think some
of these are more matters of perspective
right that like this micro targeting
depending upon your political view can
be either for any of these examples that
were using right just in terms of
addressing Paige I think there is also a
positive side to it that it's easier to
control them and monitor and enforce
something because you know all the Nazis
are actually Facebook has the data you
can actually subpoena the data and find
these people more easily it's more
difficult to send detectives right
perhaps I mean I don't know if you can
actually subpoenaed the data and what
are the subpoena will result
perhaps yes sada I think was next okay
so I I wonder if we can go to a level
higher because I think if okay let's
just do an imaginary thing
Facebook is a logistics company they're
like taking containers around with
information and what they do is to do
that as efficiently as possible and one
way to do that is to make containers
that are popular go viral okay so in
that sense they don't care about whether
you're automating love or hate or any
other emotion in between but what they
really want is to you know engage engage
audiences and make revenue or some sort
in which case the problem is at a higher
level which is that they're maybe
breaking something like contextual
integrity right by basically removing
all contextual information except that
was relevant for logistics right and and
maybe what they're also where the kind
of violence happens is that all the
content flow questions we might have
right look what do we think about
hateful information or organizing turns
into logistics questions so they'll say
I will remove that person for you I will
remove that info for you and then the
problem is solved where is the
higher-order problem of treating all
information as logistics and all
societal problems of logistics is not
addressing could that be like a helpful
way incident trying to say it could be
good it could be bad because they really
don't care right so I really like this
idea of taking this one level higher and
I think maybe that's one of the reasons
could you ask me to give this talk
because this this this really gives an
example of we need to stop thinking
about this just like as in the
individual examples we need a bigger
picture view we need a more foundational
view maybe the same way differential
privacy thought about privacy maybe the
same way contextual integrity thought
about privacy right we need to take this
bigger view and who better to do this
then this this group that has experience
in taking the better view and and
bringing the better tools until
the conversation I do a very small
addition I think it's absolutely crucial
but one of the things that Facebook has
done from the beginning is only allow
people to like things and I think that
shows that their intention is maybe not
just increasing ad revenue that's quite
clear but there is the assumption that
by different tricks you can solve the
problem and I think that's very
important yes even if you only allow
people to lie that doesn't mean they're
not gonna like hate speech
so there's an assumption that this may
be solvable by way of an algorithms or
etc and that's basically what you're
questioning yeah I mean longer
conversation but I think all the
solutions they propose are logistical
ones right like they basically react
about tonight yeah yeah and you know
they have now offered different offers
like do people share news and if they
don't then we can maybe reduce the
quality like we can say the quality is
less because they read it and didn't
share so it must not be good like you
know and these are all not about the
content of how you interact and again
like information is containers and
logistics and not going into it's not
about knowledge it's not about reasoning
it's not about values or morals right
like that's I think the thing that we
need to look at and say what do we mean
by that and what do we want to do with
that Thanks teacher I think about
reaching people mom as the example
you're using the geo-targeting as about
attacks that are presence
right and we think about like your
presence in a particular location as
being something that leaks information
or F itself I'm just curious about why
why you didn't conceptualize that as a
privacy issue versus an automating heat
issue and and in the on the other way
that I would think about it that would
move away from me and I was about hater
is about love it's it's trying to
influence somebody's decision-making
right and when we think about privacy we
think about its own autonomy and zones
of autonomous decision-making and you
know I think part of what what you were
using the Planned Parenthood example is
that we have this understanding that
there are times in people's lives I mean
we're not you know fully autonomous
beings but there are times when we kind
of try to privilege this is a decision
you really get to make on your own and
it's the intrusion at that particular
sort of decision-making point so it I
think like the automating heat off might
complicate some like different kinds of
abstractions that you might make and
understanding presence as as something
that can be a very revealing is
something in health privacy a lot right
you can acknowledge whether or not
somebody's in an institution generally
but not a pretend institution
treats people for mental health just as
an example right because we understand
that the mere prep their mere presence
tells you something about their health
status whereas telling you that they're
in the hospital right it doesn't tell
you the same sort of information so I
think things like connects to different
ways in which we conceptualize the
leakiness of certain locations
thank you I agree with both comments
that this can be both in that privacy
space and automating hate space and also
agree that this this needs a better name
better could conceptualisation let's
let's take that to their unbaked ideas
and think about this as part of that
Chris if I couldn't empathize at this
point I think did the problem here in
this as she's put it is there's a series
of hacks to fix the system but I think
the problems with the underlying system
and then it doesn't care about your
subjective preferences and dreams or
whatever what it cares about is how you
act and so it's behavioral list and it's
ultimately it's it's behavioralist in
the same sense that we as researchers we
care about what research subjects do and
we don't necessarily care about what
they think or if they like a different
world and so on so I see this like the
social concern to me is not necessarily
privacy or these other things it's that
the system is a liberal it doesn't fit a
kind of classical liberal framework of
respecting individuals for their wants
and involving them in these decisions
instead it's just asking the question is
Alexandra here is she there did she do
this
and there's it so we are basically all
subjects rather than people and I wonder
if that makes sense - yeah just so I
just say this is a liberal in an
Enlightenment sense and that's why we
should care about is these things
agree to the unbaked ideas let's today
how to turn this from from like
understanding and cut suppose shows
Asian the way you guys conceptualize it
to actionable things that ad platforms
could do
they like a comment on the idea that
Facebook's just like in control business
company and I think they actually have a
very strong interest in the context and
content of different things
and this is not from interested for the
good of society it's actually impacts
our advertising bottom liner because
advertisers don't want to advertise
their Pepsi NEXT to some knots and post
facebook what's that stuff off of there
it isn't like a really sterilized happy
content so they actually have a lot of
interest in getting the stuff off of
there and I would not think of them it's
just like other network they left
whatever goes by and not care what it's
like yeah I pushed this idea that is
just in like a logistics operation yeah
I think that would have been true if
Facebook would've never looked at the
information or analyzed it to try to see
what in there just transformed boxes for
good information from one end to another
but this is very far from what they're
doing they're actually really analyzing
to be happier this really underlies in
the Texas is within the lights and so on
and so I think this is giving them
leeway and a way to get around the
question of being responsible for things
that they are doing I think because
Facebook is not really doing the
logistic operation we need to move
beyond the framework of protection
integrity that mostly looks at the
logistic part of of how information is
handled how information is transmitted
and so on because we need to also look
at the question of how the information
is being actually used in variety of
facebook so this is one comment in the
other one is I really
we that there should we should try to
analyze the mission of Facebook has as
an advertiser not only Fitness also the
other online advertisers and to
understand the and qualifier exactly the
limits or the the amount in which these
systems actually contradict what we
understand as privacy and this is work
that we haven't I mean except for some
work that you've done that we don't have
like a theory that encapsulate this and
this is something that should we should
do it and I agree with coming just just
one thing that doesn't really directly
contradict anything anybody's saying
with solutions more complicated is it
it's also not especially accurate to
think of Facebook as a monolithic entity
right it's this kind of largely
organized collection of people
implementing this somewhat organized
platform it's not the case that there
are people at Facebook who understand
like any one person at Facebook who
understands all the moving parts right
people have different views of different
levels but you know that that makes it
extra comple you know assigning
intentionality to some of these
decisions it's maybe like not quite the
right I wouldn't push back on that and
say that's you know if if this is what
you as a very wealthy company have been
doing and positioning as your
competitive advantage if you don't have
people who understand the system then
you should hire those people and have
them work and understand the system and
have the intentionality and have the
tools yeah I'm not I'm not doing it as
an attack on any particular Facebook
employee but as a company that that's
doing this I think the company has
responsibility to do this right and in
the current form
it's not it's not perfect so yeah we're
eating into like you and I already quite
a bit faster yes so my third point about
these systems is actually maybe even
more controversial so yes let's let's
make it there and the the third aspect
that I think these systems create I
related to discrimination and unfairness
so again going back to you know you can
pick people who are interested in
particular things in 2016 again
ProPublica nerdist ad you can run
housing ads and say oh I want to target
people who are likely to move and are
interested in buying a house but I want
to exclude people who are African
American or Asian American or Hispanic
from my hands so I can run a housing ad
but you know I can select carefully the
race of people who I want to see these
ads and this perhaps violates the Fair
Housing Act of 1968 and when Facebook
was told about this they said okay we're
gonna update our policies to make sure
that damn advertisers understand that
this is not legitimate and we're gonna
do stronger enforcement but when the
same author is checked about a year
later all the same things were still
possible on the platform similar thing
happens in relation to job and again
ProPublica found that companies were
using facebook to exclude older workers
from job ads remember you can select the
the age range and they were some
some advertisers were targeting only men
even when you know gender wasn't totally
relevant to and Facebook's response to
this was we're just a platform and this
is the advertisers engaging in behavior
that should not be acceptable but
actually this is also an accept accepted
industry practice ever everybody is
doing this and you know perhaps this
violates the federal age discrimination
and Employment Act so there was a
lawsuit brought against Facebook on on
these issues and it was settled just
about a little over a month and a half
ago and here's Facebook's post
announcing how they're gonna address
this issue they're gonna do more to
protect against discrimination and
housing employment and credit
advertising specifically the post
emphasized that the policies prohibit
advertisers from using the tools to
discriminate then anyone who wants to
run housing employment the credit ads
will not be allowed to target by age
gender or zip code and that advertisers
in general advertisers who are running
housing employment and credit ads will
have a smaller set of targeting criteria
that are available to them so this this
is this is a this is a great step right
but the question is is this really
enough is this fully addressing the core
of the issue this essentially puts all
the blame on the advertisers and says
okay if we make sure that their tools
don't enable advertisers to discriminate
then we're in good shape and there's no
discrimination that's gonna be happening
on the platform I I don't think that
that's the case and you know I think
many people in this audience have worked
on this question for many years and let
me just explain why it's not the case
the delivery
is a complex process there is a lot of
things happening when the platform is
deciding who is gonna see each other
remember the promise that users are
gonna see ads that are relevant to them
so whether or not facebook estimates
that the ad is relevant to a particular
person plays a role and whether the
person will be shown an ad even if they
advertise their targets then there are
things like money right there's a
there's how much money in each
advertiser may have to spend and there's
things like competition like certain
people are competed for by advertisers
more than certain other people that's
just a fact and then there is also a
different frequency of platform here
some of us are on Facebook all the time
and some of us visit once a year or not
on Facebook right so combination of
these other items can result in
unfairness and and this this work I
think started with Sweeney in 2013 and
then the data at all she'll do some
Google system to work an event or
hypothesize this in general and more
theoretical context that this may be
happening oh my so let me tell you why
it's not just the operation of the
market in in my opinion so I I think
that Facebook specifically plays a role
in whether discrimination or skew in ad
delivery happens or not it's not just
the market it's not just the competition
it's not just it's not just how much the
advertisers are willing to pay and let
me let me show it to you with an example
the operation of the market is not
itself like a model
folks this is not just a market okay
we'll debate the merits of the market
arguments offline but it's not just a
market and this is a joint work with
collaborators at Northeastern and also
at upturn which is a non-profit in DC
here's what we did we decided okay we
want to measure the racial bias not
delivery but Facebook doesn't tell you
what's the race of the people that
delivers the ads to as you know they
they tell you a gender agent location so
we hacked this we created two custom
audiences from North Carolina public
records that contain race and we took
the white people from Wilmington for one
custom audience and the black people
from Greenville for another custom
audience and now we ran advertising
campaigns that taught that better custom
audience which is a combination of these
two and then when we look at the results
we see the location breakdown and so in
our case the location corresponds to
race so we can figure out what is the
race asked the people that the aunt is
delivered to and just as a sanity check
we did this for four albums one is the
left hand side is the hip-hop top hip
hop albums the right hand side adjusts
top music albums and the right-hand side
is the country music and as kind of
expected we saw that when we do run an
ad for the country music about 80
percent of the deliveries to white users
when we run a neutral one about almost
60 percent is white and then when it's
hip-hop ads
about 10% is white and the rest her
black in the delivery so that just the
sanity check the method and you can
argue this this bad is this
discrimination I don't know we can argue
that I'll fine but now let's go back to
Java ads so now we do the same thing we
create an audience that is 50% white and
50% black using custom audiences in this
North Carolina trip and then we run
identical ads for jobs with the same
budget run at the same time targeting
the same audience running over the same
time period just the only thing that
differs is the that the job that's
actually described in there and what we
see is that if you're advertised for
lumberjacks
72% of your audience is gonna be white
and if you advertise for taxi drivers
only 30% of your audience is gonna be
white even though you as an advertiser a
targeting even and so this is where I'm
claiming that this is this is not just a
market effect because all of my ads have
the same budget a competing against the
same set of other advertisers are
competing at the same time so if it was
just to market the fact I would just see
it may be the split wouldn't be 50/50
maybe it would be somewhere here but it
wouldn't be so pronounced for the
difference between lumber and there's
lots and lots of literature about that
but I don't see why so I don't see why
all they're doing
doing an optimization based on relative
gossip the delivery and the relative
returns so it's just enabling but that's
nothing to do with the they were able to
lower the cost of the distribution of
their patents and the benefits of the
distribution of their ads but companies
do that all the time whether it's right
or wrong is not the issue I don't see
why this why what you're presenting here
is any different from what any business
does I mean that's the explicit
agreement in make the decision you as
the user or you as they advertise it to
you sir
you as the user have nothing you as the
user don't have the ability benefit cost
ratio is there okay I'm I mean I have
two minutes left and we even in the
discussion so let's take this offline
but my claim here is that Facebook
actively looks at the audience that was
provided by the advertiser and decides
that within the within this audience you
know these people are more likely to
respond to the lumberjack ads and these
people are more likely to respond to
taxi ads and as a result the skew there
is a skew in racial delivery even when
the advertiser didn't intend it so to
say that the the problem was solved by
educating the advertisers and making
sure the advertiser tools do not enable
discrimination is not to solve the
problem because really the optimization
engine this
the subset of people that they add is
gonna go to and this decision is not
necessarily equitable for example by
race but you also controlled to make
sure that it wasn't and I think that is
a really important response this this
does control this does control yeah okay
so thanks teacher so this does control
for the bidding from other entities
because this ad in this and are facing
the same competition at the same time so
if if the performance is different just
because they're being out out competed
then it should be the same by race and
then after this but let's take this
apply and we did the same for housing
job ads and it turns out that for the
buy buy buy ads it goes mostly to white
and for the ramp ads it goes mostly to
black right I don't have time for that
but they have other ways to prove that
this is automated and this is not a
result of you know users initially let's
say in the first 15 minutes the white
and the black users click really
differently in that excuse the delivery
we read the paper talk to me later for
that so in conclusion I really believe
that the higher-level thinking that
theoretical computer science but in
general computer science represents
could be helpful for these for
addressing these issues and I think the
time is right for doing that so what
when country now is asking like okay
what are some of the questions that
you've been burning to solve with the
tools I am burning to solve this with
the high level tools and to actually
effect change for privacy I think coming
from a differential privacy workshop it
would be interesting to understand what
are the barriers to adopting
differential privacy for those questions
that differential privacy does solve in
these in this context and overcoming
them maybe it's different adversary
modeling maybe it's noise less privacy
like we've been talking about but
there's things to do have but we also
clearly need other approaches for
understanding campaign performance and
attribution to which comparing something
came from data privacy preserving and
also this this question of does it
really need to be the case that all the
possible data is being swept up in order
to to have a win-win situation for
individuals and advertisers maybe it's
possible with less with less data less
less risky data automation of hate oh we
had a good discussion of the ideas and
finally for the questions of
discrimination and unfairness I think we
need to think about the system
holistically and understand what
fairness should mean in this context and
how can we define it and then how can we
optimize towards it and how should the
ad platforms optimize towards it and one
attempt on this is galleon on Tuesday at
11:00
stay tuned but also I think we need to
have ways to test for whatever is
happening these systems both white box
when you have partial access internally
but also as black box where regulators
and members of the public or researchers
or journalists should be able to test
and what are the best ways what are the
best systemic ways to enable that so
that you can you don't have to do
one time hacks with North Carolina thank
you comment from Jamie yeah yeah so I
think I want to this is supposed to be
questions and discussions I have Matt I
have I have a few things that I want to
mostly let people assess them I think
people have lots of things to say but I
had a couple of like medically so one
thing that I noticed both while
listening to your talk and hearing their
comments from peanut gallery is the idea
that you know we need to generalize and
abstract from specific examples to
thinking about sort of more foundational
questions about what you like or dislike
about what targeting advertising
targeted advertising allowance and I
actually want to not disagree with that
as an important direction but say that
abstraction and generalization being
fundamental to computational thinking
might be one of the reasons we found
ourselves in this place to begin with so
the fact that computer scientists want
to solve the most general problem
possible ignoring the context from which
a dataset has come might really be one
of the reasons we found ourselves in
this place to be good with so you know
foundational to solving problems as
computer scientist is thinking in sort
of this abstract general way but I think
it can actually be problematic than
simplistic I also want to sort of guide
people towards thinking about whether
thinking about blame is necessarily the
best way forward so we're currently in a
set this situation where there are all
sorts of advertising platforms that are
doing all kinds of personalized targeted
advertising and I think we generally say
who's to blame when something goes wrong
and I think perhaps a more fruitful way
to move forward is to think about
which parts of these ecosystems are most
ripe for useful interventions not
necessarily who is responsible but
instead thinking about who has the right
information tools and position in these
markets